MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
In the previous
lecture, we have seen
how the gauge bosons, the W,
and the Z boson acquire mass,
while the photon
remains massless,
through the Higgs mechanism.
We introduced a new field,
a new complex doublet field,
the Higgs field,
which then broke,
through its vacuum expectation
value, the symmetry.
And then through the
coupling to the gauge bosons,
they acquired mass.
Right.
But we also have to find a
solution for the fermions.
You cannot simply add a fermion
mass onto the Lagrangian.
That would change, or
that could violate, break,
the gauge invariant.
So how do we do this?
We do this in a
very similar way--
even easier.
But before we look
into how this is done,
let's have a look at
the masses itself.
It's spectacular.
The top quark is our
heaviest known fermion.
It has a mass of about 172 GeV.
The tau has a mass of 1.7 GeV.
The muon is an
order of magnitude
lighter, with 0.1 GeV.
And for the electron, we
have to go to 0.51 MeV.
OK?
And we haven't even
tried to understand,
or we were not able
to measure, actually,
the masses of neutrinos.
We will talk about neutrinos in
one of the following lectures.
So here you have six
orders of magnitude.
And you have to go
further down here in order
to find the neutrinos
on this mass scale.
So we have to have a
mass-giving mechanism which
allows this broad spectrum
of masses to occur.
And the very simple
ad hoc mechanism
which was introduced
to the standard model
is one where the particle simply
interacts with the Higgs field.
So we have our Higgs field here.
Let's say we have a
left-handed particle coming in.
And the interaction
with the Higgs field
turns it into a
right-handed particle.
This is a little bit
simplified, but what
we do there here is
simply introducing terms
into the Lagrangian
which do nothing else.
We turn our
left-handed particles,
via the interaction
with the Higgs field,
into right-handed, and
the other way around.
And we have to do this
for up-type particles
and for down-type particles.
So here is another view of this.
The strength here is the mass
of the particle over the vacuum
expectation value.
This number here, this
number, this lambda d,
it's the so-called
Yukawa coupling.
And those Yukawa couplings now
change from fermion to fermion.
Each fermion comes with
their own Yukawa coupling.
It's basically a free
parameter in our theory
in the standard model.
So instead of talking about the
masses being free parameters,
we talk about the coupling
to the Higgs field
as free parameter.
But they are one and the same.
All right.
So this was rather
straightforward.
It's a simple coupling; you
introduce this term ad hoc,
and then hope for the
best that it's actually
realized in nature.
And you'll see
that this is indeed
the case for some of
the fermions later.